you'll never walk alone es ist die
berühmteste fußballhymne der welt ja
eigentlich ist dieser satz untrennbar
mit dem fc liverpool und 1000 singenden
fans im stadion verbunden bis jetzt
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat den
legendären fußball spruch heute zum
leitprinzip für seine krisenpolitik
gemacht der kanzler unterbricht seinen
alkohol und leistet einen krisen
dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen
zeiten bewältigen dass wir
zusammenhalten dass es entscheidend
niemand wird mit seinen
herausforderungen und problemen alleine
gelassen keine einzelne bürgerin kein
einzelner bürger auch nicht die
unternehmen in diesem land herr you'll
never walk alone wir werden
zusammenhalten jan schäfer unser bild
politikchef jetzt hier bei mir im studio
bundeskanzler olaf scholz ich habs
gerade schon gesagt er hat extra für
einen tag seinen urlaub unterbrochen um
diesen krisen zu leisten wie bewertest
du den und was will er damit bezwecken
will er uns einschwören will er uns
beruhigen was genau ist sein ziel mit so
einem satz ja er will uns einschwören
auf eine sehr sehr schwere zeit die vor
uns liegt jeder spürt dass im
portemonnaie nicht nur das tägliche
leben ist teuer geworden aber auch mit
blick auf vor allem auf die gasrechnung
sind die preise ganz schön nach oben
geschossen und das was olaf scholz heute
gemacht wird auch mit diesem spruch das
ist nicht mehr und nicht weniger als
eine deutschland garantie die er gegeben
hat also allen bürgern unternehmen so
hat das ja auch gesagt niemand soll
zurückgelassen werden es werden alle
mitgenommen also diese deutschland
garantie zielt darauf ab dass eigentlich
niemand in dieser krise die da auf uns
zukommt und in die wir rein steuern
zurückgelassen wird entscheidende frage
ist kann er dieses versprechen halten
oder eben nicht wir kennen ja diese
kanzler garantien schon aus der
vergangenheit 2008 ihre sparbücher sind
sicher ich denke auch nochmal an diesem
historischen satz von angela merkel wir
schaffen das wie sehr können wir da
jetzt drauf vertrauen
also wir schaffen das war keine war
keine garantie dass ein mutmacher
die garantie vollkommen richtig war 2008
mit den sparbüchern am ende muss man
sagen kam es bei dieser garantie nie
dazu dass sie eigentlich gezogen worden
ist das war eher eine beruhigungspille
ja am ende wird sich zeigen ob die
politik von olaf scholz ob die politik
der ampel ob aber auch die geopolitik
also auch das was war die mir putin
macht dazu beiträgt dass olaf scholz
dieses deutschland versprechen halten
kann oder eben nicht ganz klar und das
muss man glaube ich mit blick auf das
sagen was an maßnahmen auch an
stützungsmaßnahmen nicht nur für firmen
sondern für die bürgerinnen und bürger
geplant ist wird es am ende sehr sehr
teuer das heißt das was wir uns jetzt
oder auch im nächsten jahr an hilfe an
gegenseitiger hilfe beispielsweise beim
thema heizkosten erkaufen das müssen wir
irgendwann auch in den nächsten jahren
wieder zurück bis es gerade schon gesagt
entlastungen für die bürger unter
anderem mit einer wohngeldreform in
diesem abschnitt waren da auch noch
einmal anschauen
es wird zum anfang des nächsten jahres
eine große wohngeldreform geben darüber
sind wir uns in der regierung einig wir
wollen den kreis der berechtigten
haushalte ausweiten sodass mehr
bürgerinnen und bürger arbeitnehmern
arbeitnehmer rentnerinnen rentner ganz
besonders die auch davon an spar auf
ansprüche haben davon profitieren können
und wir wollen in diese wohngeldreform
eine heizkostenpauschale gewissermassen
dauerhaft integrieren sollen bestimmte
arbeitnehmergruppen und rentner von der
wohngeldreform profitieren aber wer
genau ist das und wie die bei jahren
wird das ganze finanziert genau das
steht natürlich noch gar nicht fest klar
ist nur es sollen mehr werden das heißt
der anspruchs bereich oder bereich der
ihn die anspruch auf so einen wohngeld
auf einen zuschuss zu ihrer mieter haben
der wird steigen da wird es dann in der
ampelkoalition zahlreiche gespräche auch
noch gms werden und das haben wir gehört
bereits gespräche geführt beispielsweise
über die frage was mache ich eigentlich
wenn ich weiter gas preis so stark
steigt meine gasrechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen kann kann mir dann der gast
anbieter künftig den gashahn einfach zu
drehen und da gibt es aktuell mehrere
möglichkeiten optionen die diskutiert
werden beispielsweise über ein modell
dass dann der vermieter ein zinsloses
darlehen erhält um diesen ausgleich zu
bezahlen also der mieter soll sein gas
vertrag behalten dem soll nicht
gekündigt werden er soll also eine
einigermaßen warme wohnung behalten
können und der vermieter beispielsweise
soll in vorleistung treten also das sind
dinge die jetzt diskutiert werden olaf
scholz hat gesagt zum 1 1 23 soll dieser
reform in kraft treten bis dahin müssen
wir alles ist noch fünfeinhalb monate
unter noch viel diskutiert werden
schauen wir noch einmal in einen anderen
ausschnitt rein denn scholz kam auch auf
den großen gasversorger uniqa zu
sprechen das unternehmen steckt in einer
tiefen krise und scholz kündigte an
unter die
werden einsteigen bei juniper mit 30
prozent anteil des unternehmens
30 prozent an dem unternehmen warum ist
uniqa überhaupt in die schieflage
geraten und warum wird genau dieses
unternehmen jetzt unterstützt es war zu
beginn der krise dass deutschland
ungefähr 53 prozent seines gases aus
russland importiert hat uniqa war ein
sehr sehr großer gasimporteur jetzt
wissen wir es gibt weniger gas aus
russland muss sich führt zu einem
deutlich höheren preis auf dem weltmarkt
mit gas eindecken um die laufenden
verträge mit den kunden auch zu erfüllen
so und das führt dazu wenn man die
preise aber nicht gleichzeitig an die
endkunden oder die preise für die
verbraucher erhöht dass man teuer
einkaufen muss aber die kosten dafür
nicht weitergeben kann und so ist
juniper in eine massive schieflage
geraten jetzt steigt der staat eine bis
zu acht milliarden euro olaf scholz hat
gesagt das wird nicht das letzte
unternehmen seien wir hören aus einer
runde von scholz und dem
ministerpräsidenten von heute dass es
bereits forderung gibt so etwas auch bei
den stadtwerken zu machen wissen auch
dass viele stadtwerke ja gas aus
russland bezogen haben ebenfalls jetzt
unter finanzdruck geraten sind also in
finanziellen schieflagen und unterarm
hat markus söder bereits gesagt er
möchte das auch stadtwerke künftig
staatliche hilfen bekommen können